like when Dane ruled the world there's
some danger to do a love day I'm not
[ __ ] on Dane there's something nice
to do that rubbed me wrong
always always hey guys
Dane Cook here I got a big secret to
tell you guys I'm not gonna tell you
today I can't tell you yet but I got a
big secret coming tomorrow you guys hear
this you guys are gonna lose your mind I
felt like going like that [ __ ] work
though but yeah I did but it always
rubbed me wrong so I was like hey man
this isn't your this is your ego talking
like this isn't this is kind of gross
how so because I don't what was his
secret
I never fat to find out how you know
yeah like just like [ __ ] see he
created all the [ __ ] I'm doing he
created all this he did it the whole
[ __ ] game said hold my beer and then
Brandon no no I don't know if I was that
close but what I will say I will say I'm
not even remotely you know will say that
like that like a Dane Dane was a pioneer
I'll tell you what I'll tell you it was
more effective for me then I got a big
secret things and and I would say I'd
say ball I'm saying this if they don't
say big secret I would say I would he my
dad called me and going buddy do you
know a guy named Dane Cook and I don't
know and he goes he's on the cover of
USA Today and by the way that was the
shift when Dane like like I remember
calling the game he was the first you
can learn this stuff you didn't like
from him and apply that as well you can
go I didn't like this [ __ ] I love this
[ __ ] yeah but here's the other thing
about Dane I know every what's this [ __ ]
on Dane and whatever I like Dane he's
been great to me James always been evil
still [ __ ] crush of Rome dude dude
you should Ryan you remember hold on
with that goeth got that [ __ ] to
the dance dude he killed me he know he's
still but here's my babies if you tell
me something everything we're doing
still [ __ ] you understand people were
bombing when Dane was in that tank top
there were still comical doesn't bombed
they would Dave Attell would bomb louis
c.k would bomb that was how they did
stand-up you would bomb and bomb and you
get a couple good ones Dan he's never
[ __ ] monster was Evel Knievel him in
Dublin's every he said
watch like watching the first caveman
make fire I couldn't speak I watched
Senna died with this he got me back into
stand if I wasn't doing competence but I
watched me store a few weeks yes I'm
tell me how don't respond you know what
he's a real calm hell it was just crowd
work he's a real cop don't want to fall
in four years I watched him do the
Boston Comedy Club gala I watched him do
the Boston comedy I was at that taping
oh yeah yeah well as a fan no no as a
friend I knew Dan back oh you'd and aim
for as long as I've known bill you ain't
sat me down in his apartment he's real
live or what do you have rope in my robe
for Dane okay never own fur Dane Dane
sat me down he's live in an apartment
off of Fairfax it was it's the old John
the old Kennedy compound there's more
than one of those beautiful buildings
I'd ever seen one of the most building
up beautiful apartments I've ever seen
and he was we went over to play guitars
and your [ __ ] go see a movie and he
was and he was just going over his
computer the whole time I thought that
thought that so anyway now I go what are
you doing and he goes oh dude let me
show you this is gonna change the game
you need to get a myspace profile and I
was like smart I was like huh by the way
I was like good luck you know buddy
catch me doing that [ __ ] yeah if I had
listened he answered every eve
everything I talk to him he said he said
I started noticing people were emailing
me and a lot of people and and I said to
myself if I if I start making a log of
these emails and letting people know
that I'm gonna be back there and that's
what he started doing sweet we got a hem
on the show we I've talked him the other
day I want to come on the show I'll tell
you what man if you think now think
about this right we're talking about
game changers know if you're thinking I
had anything even remotely to do with
Dane that's nothing that's nothing think
about Rogan what he did he broke the
[ __ ] game when he decided it's not
cheap Harrison think they're all
different no compare but I'm saying what
did what Dane did was just as as
effectively Rogan oh yeah you know no no
right right so Dane broke the mold Joe
broke the mold dude Schultz was breaking
the [ __ ] mold crap you guys broke the
mold you and you guys doing this podcast
popped and everyone was like dude
fighter in the kids getting down fighter
in the kid Todd because like at the time
pioneer comedian at the time dude cage
fighter dirty
it was earned kick comedian two dudes
doing a coupon cast everyone was doing
the solo mode everyone was like it don't
Tata Christine we're doing them but like
me Joey re Duncan everyone was doing the
solo mode and you guys showed up that
was a [ __ ] game changer do I love I
like I hope to god I live long enough to
read a book about what has happened in
comedy from like for my cousin I mean
just my perspective of of getting in and
when I started I didn't know people
didn't do the road no one did the road
you lived in New York or you lived in LA
they just didn't know that we just wrote
comics there were Road comics like like
the [ __ ] and and JJ Medicine Hat
they were Road dudes and Kirk Nolan
there was a guy named Charlie enough Jim
Breuer who's not the same Jim Breuer
Road guy all these road guys did did the
road and then you in New York comics who
would kind of do some like in Long
Island and new you and down the coast
but they weren't going in technically
the funny Mo's and then everything
changed and like David Spade would do
Tempe improv and I would see that no go
oh wow then they offer you to do the
road you're like because what happened
is the Irvine improv open like 13 clubs
the funny bones open like 20 Club and
they started blowing up the road I mean
you're right when you talk about [ __ ]
Theatre comics you go there was when we
were when we've started there was not
joke when bill burr how they'll tell you
right now yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your
tongue oh good what's gonna happen what
are you gonna do use some of that boxing
you've been doing
[Laughter]